[Music]
we've had our fair share of tears thanks
to some of the most heart-wrenching and
dramatic series that animes given us but
I figured out that limiting my
recommendations to ten titles just won't
do it anime has so much to offer so here
we are as I present volume 2 of the top
10 anime that will make you cry sit back
and enjoy as we take another dive into
the world of dramatic anime that tug at
those harsh strings of yours
[Music]
we start off this list with a perennial
favorite five centimeters per second 5
centimeters per seconds a beautiful
series of films about love that persists
despite the pain of being pulled apart
by fate in a setup you may be familiar
with 5 centimeters per second revolves
around Takaki and Akari two classmates
who grow together and become close
friends the time comes when they're
separated due to family circumstances
time goes by and their distance from
each other both physically and
emotionally grows
however they reminisce about their
childhood moments with the hope of one
day reuniting if you light your name
don't miss 5 centimeters per second the
series of films is yet another beautiful
work of Shinkai that strongly
incorporates themes of love growing up
separation and moving on with life
[Music]
at number nine we have one of the more
popular anime at the start of the decade
Angel Beats have you ever thought of
what lies after death for Otonashi the
afterlife can be summed up as highschool
purgatory place where students refused
to move on to the next life due to
unfinished business now as he awakens in
this purgatory Otonashi encounters Yuri
the leader of the SSS a group that seeks
to fight a white-haired girl named ten
sheep however he believes that there's
more to this mysterious girl than what
he's led to know his encounters with
this girl leads him to start the path to
recovering his memories and knowing more
about this afterlife he does it again
with another excellent visual novel that
serves as the basis for this anime I'd
argue that angel beats a strongest point
besides the visual and musical
presentation is the characters each
major character comes with a certain
amount that makes you want to know more
about them and it's these backstories
that help push the series into the list
of top dramatic anime
[Music]
next up we have a Ghibli film whisper of
the heart
directed by Yoshi foo Macondo whisper of
the heart is the story of Shizuka a
young bookworm who has a passion for
writing she soon notices that Seiji
ozawa checks out the book she loves she
follows a cat the board to train and
finds herself in an antique shop owned
by an old man named Misha once more the
boy that annoys her is say gene is
grandson and isn't anything like she
thought he was in contrast to the other
movies by Ghibli whisper of the heart
doesn't have many magical and fantasy
elements the drama and relationships in
the film is pure and realistic and not a
product of some magical adventure or
incident not to say that it isn't so in
other films of the studio because that's
farthest from the truth but the
characters in this movie come off as
genuine and endearing perhaps owing to
the realistic setup the seventh place
anime that we're taking a look at is
Tokyo magnitude 8.0 and here I was
wondering how long it would be to the
disaster series made this list this
anime focuses on a topic very close to
Japan earthquakes while visiting a
robotics exhibition siblings Mirai and
Yuki find themselves in the midst of a
disaster of catastrophic proportions a
magnitude of 8.0 earthquake strikes
devastating the city of Tokyo luckily
for them they meet mari
a motorcycle delivery woman and a single
mother together with Mari the siblings
begin the long journey back home
Tokyo magnitude 8.0 is a wild
rollercoaster of emotions of course we
expect a disaster series to have its
fair share of Downers however it manages
to take a look at what it's like to be
in the midst of a disaster and make it
engaging and immersive character drama
is handled well and some of the truly
heart-wrenching moments come entirely
out of nowhere the story of survival and
determination isn't something you'd want
to miss if you want to shed a few tears
for endearing characters
[Music]
before continuing the video I'd like to
give a shout out to the sponsor of this
video astral Chronicles astral
Chronicles is a fantasy JRPG with an
all-star cast of Japanese voiceovers it
has a very rich storyline which we don't
usually see from other mobile RPGs in
this game players are on a mission to
reverse the future called from earth to
the astral world to embark on an epic
adventure together with the heroine you
can assemble more than 50 legendary
heroes as you explore the astral realm
and raveling plots of intrigue in this
side-scrolling adventure and guess what
each of them will have their own
background story and personality in the
game players can gain characters by
summon and improve your friendship with
each character learning skills from them
so that to enhance yourself with more
than a hundred skills rather than a
normal RPG in common fixed four skills
right now they're collaborating with law
of creation the most powerful hero
ultimate weapon Pandora Z is coming to
the astral realm and now her ultimate
weapon form Pandora Z will teleport to
the astral realm today download now to
recruit her in your mega team so what
are you waiting for
use the link in the description below to
download astral Chronicles for free
[Music]
coming in at number six is a place
further than the universe 16 year old
Mari has one dilemma that I'm sure
you've been through in her 16 years of
existence she's yet to truly do anything
in her life like a lot of teenagers she
wants to make the most of her youth but
nothing seems to click that is until one
day she meets Sherazi a girl looking for
her mom who apparently disappeared in
Antarctica finally finding the goal that
she's been looking for mari quickly
jumps at the opportunity
joining the expedition to Antarctica and
on with two other girls here Nutter and
yuzu key to be honest when I saw the
posters and the promo material for this
anime I didn't expect a tear jerker at
all I was actually expecting a quirky
and comfy show about outdoor activities
similar to something like Eureka the
journey to Antarctica isn't all sunshine
and rainbows and everything it's boiling
point as the series approaches the
climax trust me when I say that this is
one of the most unexpectedly
heart-aching shows you'll see number 5
we have yet another anime movie this
time it's Macchio when the promised
flower blooms a 2018 movie from the
brains of renowned writer mario karta
machia when the promised flower blooms
tells the story of the titular character
she's aloft a member of a special race
who lived for hundreds of years
one night soldiers from the Musante
Empire longing for a way to attain
immortality attacked the law village
separating machia from her people left
alone machia finds an infant boy who's
lost his parents
despite racial differences machia adopts
him and raises him as her son and
beginning a story of familiar love that
transcends generations despite all the
promo material setting up the movie to
be about romance it ended up being about
motherhood and familiar love making all
the more tear-jerking to put it simply
Marcius life is filled with tragedy be
sure to bring lots of tissues when you
decide to see this movie you'll need
them
[Music]
that's uber and for a fourth anime film
that made it to the list we take a look
at when Marnie was there based on a
classic or children's novel with the
same title when Marnie was there is the
story of Anna in order to work around
her health problems she sent to live
with her relatives in a seaside area
here she finds an abandoned mansion that
happens to house a blonde girl named
Marnie for some strange reason money
looks like the Gilda and has been seeing
in her dreams what's with this girl and
what connections does she have with
Anna's family personally speaking I find
this movie somewhere in the middle
amongst all the masterpieces the studio
ghibli has churned out it may not be as
exciting as there are the fantasy films
but when it comes to the ability to make
you sad it's right up there without
spoiling it I think it delivers well on
its themes of family specifically
abandonment issues and accepting where
you have the movies not tragic but is
filled with bittersweet moments
involving acceptance and loss
[Music]
Arina naginata coca no c'mon Osaka de
Souza's metabiotic Anita HT Nino toka
detonated
Corrado society Don Allah Utah cantata
[Music]
taking third place in our ranking for
volume 2 of anime that will make you cry
is Rainbow seven inmates all detained
for serious criminal offenses during
post World War two Japan that's the set
up that rainbow drops us in the story
starts with Mario minakami being sent to
prison along with five other teenagers
awaiting them is Sakuragi an older
inmate who becomes a mentor figure to
them not only do they have to enjoy the
tormenting conditions of jail but they
also have to go through a slew of
sadistic characters that seem bent on
making their lives hell despite its grim
and gritty overall feel rainbow at its
core is a show that features friendship
rainbow might not be melodramatic but it
does have some gripping and downright
depressing moments it's not a show for
the faint-hearted but those who braved
through it will surely find a rewarding
and realistic show about bonds and
relationships also make sure you don't
skip the opening for the epic theme song
[Music]
nine in Morioka the number to animate on
a list is to the forest of Firefly
lights what is it with fireflies and
dramatic anime movies first grave of the
fireflies and now this
anyway this anime tells the story of
Hotaru a six year old who loses her way
in a forest inhabited by mountain
spirits and other youkai there she
encounters jinn a mysterious entity with
silver hair whom she forms a friendship
with however he warns the girl of a
curse that would make him disappear if a
human touches him their blossoming
relationship is put to the test as
Hotaru matures and grows up into a high
school girl to the forest of Firefly
Lights is a short film adaptation of a
one-shot manga despite his short runtime
it's well paced and I never actually
felt it was too short when I watched it
the plot is very simple but I still
found myself touched as the climactic
act comes rolling around if you're
looking for a quick fix for dramatic
anime that'll make you cry then add this
one to your list
[Music]
[Music]
lastly we cap off our list with I want
to eat your pancreas oh look at IO that
wouldn't look out of place in some sort
of zombie apocalypse movie contrary to
expectations I want to eat your pancreas
is anything but that in fact it's quite
the opposite a grounded school drama set
up in a very familiar world the story
centers on a protagonist that a lot of
people can probably relate to a loner
withdrawn and detached from the world by
choice living for no one but for his
love for books his life changes when he
finds a diary belonging to his classmate
Sakura who's pretty much the complete
opposite of him it turns out that this
energetic girl is hiding a secret she's
dying of a pancreatic disease and
doesn't want anyone else to know about
in order to maintain her regular life
she decides to spend her last few months
with this protagonist who promises to
keep her secret arguably the setup
doesn't seem special or unique and
uneven dare to call the film predictable
however I want to eat your pancreas
execute everything in a powerful way
that's sure to resonate with a lot of
hearts out there you know how at times
you can see what's coming in an anime
that you still can't prevent it from
strongly resonating with you that's the
type of feeling that I want to eat your
pancreas elicits and that's why it finds
itself at the top of this list
[Music]
with that we conclude the second list of
anime that will surely make you cry
there's a lot of movies come to think of
it now isn't there well will there be a
volume 3 of this list in the future who
knows if this video gets 5,000 likes I
definitely consider making another one
there is surely a lot of other
tear-jerking anime that deserve a spot
on one of these lists if you've got any
suggestions about them make sure to have
your voice heard through the comments
section don't forget to check out our
sponsors game astral Chronicles the
links in the description I'll see you
next time on beanie tube
no super bear mama died here like their
come on
all night you may walk me down
[Music]